[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
vous êtes sur le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité
véritable vitrine de la profession des
services de l'automobile le campus
ouvert ses portes en septembre 2018 et
il s'étend sur cinq hectares
douze mille mètres carrés de bâtiments
est quasiment de 1000 m² d'ateliers il
propose une offre de formation complète
du préapprentissage jusqu'au diplôme
d'ingénieur en passant par le siaap et
le bac pro et le bts et la licence
professionnelle dans tous les domaines
aussi bien le domaine de la moto du vélo
de l'auto tant sur la partie commerce
que sur la partie maintenance le campus
peut accueillir jusqu'à 1000 personnes
c'est un véritable lieu de démonstration
d'expérimentation et de formation
plusieurs publics se croiser semaine
tous les jours puisque nous accueillons
à la fois des jeunes en alternance en
contrat d'apprentissage contrat de
professionnalisation des demandeurs
d'emploi en reconversion et des salariés
en formation continue
le campus illustre les attentes des
entreprises entreprises qui recrutent et
qui ont besoin d'un outil de formation
pour assurer la relève
former les futurs salariés de la branche
est fort mais également les salariés qui
sont en entreprise
[Musique]
l'objectif du campus bas c'est de
pouvoir promouvoir les métiers des
services de l'automobile pouvoir
renouveler la population salariée former
la relève et former les salariés qui
sont actuellement en entreprise et
répondre aux enjeux que les entreprises
doit relever au défi que les entreprises
doivent relever aussi bien technologique
qu'écologique
[Musique]
oh